Our next lemma states the key property
of a phase of
the Hopcroft–Karp algorithm.
Each phase increases the length of
the shortest path by at least two.
For the proof, we'll let Q be
a shortest augmenting path
after a phase that augmented
with paths of length k.
It's impossible for Q to be less than k,
by a previous lemma which showed that
augmenting by a shortest augmenting path
never decreased the minimum
augmenting path length.
On the other hand, Q being equal to
k implies that Q is vertex disjoint
from all paths found in the previous
phase, by the lemma we just showed.
But then it would have
been part of the phase,
so that doesn't make any sense either.
Thus, Q is greater than k and
it also has to be odd, so
the size of Q must be equal to k plus 2.
k itself was, of course, odd as well.
And that completes the lemma.